hello everyone this is Amir from audio
songs review continuing the series I
started on explaining in detail what the
measurements uh show for each category
product
I thought I uh get into uh Power
amplifiers I've been testing a ton of
them as of late and I thought it'd be a
good next one to do after the speaker
measurements that I just did a few days
ago
um so let's get into that hopefully you
know what a power amplifier is or
integrated amplifier is it's it's a
device that you feed it line level
inputs whether it's uh XLR or RCA inputs
and then the output is obviously uh
speaker terminals but binding posts
sometimes the terminology confusion
people are into uh headphones they uh
it's here to board amplifier and I think
it headphone amplifier so I call these
usually power amplifiers or speaker
amplifiers although by default uh if
somebody says an amplifier they mean uh
speaker amplifier
so I'm going to walk us through a recent
review that I did and explain what each
one of the measurements uh uh show in
this case it's a new amplifier from
topping called the LA 90 discrete they
used to have an IC version of this and
the parts disappeared they couldn't get
any more of the components so they had
to switch and do their own discrete
version of it which usually results in
worse performance even though it should
theoretically allow you to do better A
lot of companies are due to screen
implementations Unfortunately they go
backwards
anyway to say compact uh desktop size
amplifier and to keep the size small and
they have this giant uh sort of Xbox
class uh laptop power supply uh
um externally that you plug it into it's
got this nice custom terminals that
screw in so it's quite Stout and nice
but you do have to find space for for
this big brick
um usually typical of my reviews I note
things like this but I don't do
extensive functionality review for that
you know you should go and watch other
reviews or just look at the user's menu
anyway
um all of my amplifier reviews uh start
with what I call dashboard the dashboard
starts with driving 5 watts of power
that's what this is 5.049 watts into a
four ohm uh node what we call dummy load
is basically very large resistors that
can dissipate a lot of power and uh the
signal that we drive into the amplifier
is one kilohertz why that well
traditionally that was what was pick
turns out perceptually the harmonics are
one killer is if you look at this is the
one color stone the harmonic slam that
two three four or five killers are not
hearing you most sensitive in this
region so it's actually not a bad choice
although I doubt that it was picked for
that reason it was probably easier to
make it one kilohertz oscillator in the
old days that was accurate than not so
anyway we follow that now I do deviate
from the typical practice in that uh
standard amplifier measurements use one
watt um yeah as far as the output power
I don't like that because in modern
times speakers have become a lot less
efficient a lot less sensitive and uh
one what doesn't get you far at all
number one number two if you measure
amplifiers one watt you're basically
measuring their noise performance
their Distortion is so low for a good
amplifier that it just gets lost whereas
at five Watts there's a shot that uh you
actually will see some distortions and
indeed we're seeing that Distortion over
here so
in this graph this one spike is what is
expected it's this sine wave that you
see on the left and everything else is
extra that unwanted if you will uh here
we see the harmonics which means
multiples of of our tone so we put in
one kilohertz we got the one kilohertz
out but we also got a two killers three
killers for I think we skipped over five
then we had six and seven and keeps
going on the good news is that if you
look at the uh amplitude of of these
spikes and go all the way to the left
you see that the worst case one is as
minus 125. uh threshold of hearing is
around -115 so even if this tone wasn't
here all we heard was a distortion which
is not going to happen but stay with me
these distortions will be provably
inaudible and for five watts and uh so
they're not of any consequence from
engineering Excellence we like to see
Zero Distortion but uh it's not going to
happen always so this assertion spikes
are you know we see them or
instrumentation is quite a bit more
sensitive than our hearing and uh but we
know and we can prove that they're 100
inaudible in here there's a little bit
of a power supply noise here at 60 hertz
and we're in 60 years country in U.S and
that's at minus 145 which is just crazy
low and not anything to worry about and
by the way sometimes this is an
instrumentation issue with real speakers
you won't see it
so this is where my eye always goes when
I first start this dashboard I look at
this call the fast Fourier transform is
basically if you take this sine wave and
decompose that you get one giant sine
wave like this which is what you see but
also the little sine waves are mixed up
with it which you cannot see in this
oscilloscope type of display so you must
decompose this into its components to be
able to see the contributions from power
supply noise and so forth
um if we take all these distortions and
add it to the noise and this is not the
true noise floor the true noise floor is
about 35 DB higher
um but if you took that the exact
correct value of it and add up the
energy of all of this and took a ratio
of that relative to our signal and
consider our signal zero
um we can compute what is called tht
plus n we said what is the ratio of all
this bad and unwanted stuff to the
signal that we do want which is one
kilohertz and then get this crazy small
number with you know percentage which is
called THC plus n ratio which you're
never going to know remember and it's
just terrible value to look at
fortunately we can take a log of that
and change a sign and we get a number in
decibels and that numbered lands around
120 DB so what is 120 DB means it means
the sum energy of the noise and
Distortion is at 120 decibels lower I'll
mentioned that one is 115 we're in full
transparency so this amplifier R is 100
transference to the source as far as you
hear is concerned I've measured about
210 amplifiers to date the Standalone
amplifiers I've made another 30 40 that
are part of avrs and other kind of
products but as far as Standalone amps
I've got that and uh if I slot this
number into what the sign at is for all
the other uh amplifiers that I've
measured it's a long list and I'll show
you the example of that with all 200 of
them but here we see that in this one
ties for number two position or number
one position with the IC version of the
same thing so the topping La 90 is
currently at 120 and the next one down
is 70 below and that's a giant Gap even
the audibility is the same it's just
first engineering accomplishment this is
superhero stuff to be able to get the
noise and Distortion to be this slow
so right away we know that we're dealing
with with a design that's gone through
incredible scrutiny and incredible skill
to be able to achieve this low level of
noise and Distortion
um one note to make very important note
about uh cyanide a lot of people
complained they said well this you know
the bigger the number doesn't tell me
that you know it sounds better it
actually does because remember I said
this number is the sum of noise and
Distortion I've already told you that
Distortion is almost minus 130. so the
thing that draw drags the cyanide from
130 to 120 is noise and to an extend the
noise floors 120 decibels lower that
means you can play music and 120
decibels and the noise floor would
essentially be inaudible you really need
to go to -1 5 DB so a lot of people even
with state-of-the-art amplifiers you can
hook them up to speakers and stick your
ear next to Twitter and you will hear
some hiss
so this is not a bogus value if you care
about his from your uh speakers uh
especially if they're sensitive
okay uh this uh amplifier like many
others comes with two different gain
settings uh
um one of them is very low which is this
low game one is that has a gate of 9.3
DB which is quite low
um and then it has a a high gang excuse
me that jumps up to 20 DB uh in the old
days uh typical gains was 25 to 30 DB
um that's way too much gain for today's
world today's world or desktop Dax and
regular high performance stacks
get an output
um up to four volts or more from their
uh balance outputs and two volts from
RCA and you don't need that much gain so
this 19 DB gain is planning and by using
more again you can actually improve the
noise performance of an amplifier excuse
me and I'll show you that in a second so
but be mindful that to get power out of
this amp with 9 DB gain you need to have
basically professional audio interface
that goes up to eight or nine ten volts
sometimes to be able to get uh full
power uh unfortunately there's no
standardization in amplifiers every
company picks a different number for
gain and there's a bit of a crap shoot
how you can drive it uh on this thing
but if the performance is good at hiking
then go ahead and use that in just about
every Source can can drive
okay so uh
um I didn't measure just a noise
performance here the noise and
Distortion were mixed up uh together
um but we can parse that out and uh
first at five Watts we see that it's got
125 DBS uh dynamic range so that means
you can again play at 120 125 DB which
is reference live concert uh level uh
loudness and your noise floor will be at
zero DB so very very very quiet
um and that's only in five watts of
playback if you let the amplifier go
it's full power it now reaches 137 DB
that's equivalent to 23 bits of
resolution
um or dynamic range and that's just
incredible this this power amplifier is
acting like a dark wood which upwards
very low power so this kind of
performance is just insanely good but
note what I've put in here that you need
6.3 volts in low gain to get to get
maximum power so a typical Dax again to
stop at five four volts or five volts so
to get the max power out of this thing
in low gain mode you need to have 6.3
volts of output
um fortunately you can switch to the
High Gain mode and if you did that in
High Gain mode now you only need two
volts to get maximum power which every
balance the output more or less can
generate but High Gain costs you some
noise Some Noise penalty we see that we
dropped 5 DB but hey 120 DB which is 20
bits of dynamic ranges or the superb and
22 bits of full power it's just
fantastic the music you listen to best
case about 1819 DB of dynamic range
anyway so what this means that this
won't add to that noise
okay
um frequency response is to be in the
old days we struggle to have flat
frequency responses and but today is
basically expected to get a flat audible
uh um uh frequency response flatness in
here means between 20 and 20 kilohertz
there's no deviation and ideally we want
it to be flat even below 20 Hertz so it
go down to 10 Hertz without subsonic uh
you know rumbles or something and let's
say in your lfiche and all uh coming out
for your movie soundtracks what have you
or even music uh on this thing I
measured uh four and eight ohms
um and uh ideally they're the same and
they are in here I'll show you an
example of one they're not the same but
you know you want to see an amplifier
that doesn't change its frequency
response depending on the load if I had
a tube amplifier with a high output
impedance uh and I change these things
you will indeed see uh oddness and
changes in here
uh crosstalk usually is not an issue
with crosstalk is a notion of how much
uh signal from one channel bleeds into
the other channel
um for us to have a sense of Separation
um we don't need 40 50 DBS uh on this
thing and uh so anything more than that
is gravy um here I've got two references
for you one is uh this 25 dollar uh let
the uh amplifier literally costs 25
bucks and you can see it's Channel
separation over here and gets pretty
poor at high frequencies at 20 kilohertz
uh it's it's only 30 DB of Channel
separation but it goes down to 60 DB or
so at at one kilohertz and then state of
the art is this Benchmark hb2 uh which
is down here by the way the IC version
of La 90 actually beats The Benchmark
for some reason I got higher value in
the air I probably should go back and
retest to see what happened here it's
odd for it to be the is High
um most amplifiers are actually worsen
this topping they're somewhere in here
so uh but again audibility is is fine
it's just that from engineering point of
view you want this to be as close as you
can to down here
uh people are usually compliant and say
oh you'll test so far have been one
frequency and music is not one frequency
so how about that well we have a test
signal that we call multi-tone has 32
tones in here and uh they're all mixed
together so always sine waves so if you
look at it it just looks like random
stuff and it actually sounds like organ
notes that are being played
simultaneously
um when we play this this is I set the
maximum to be zero so zero is the
reference and then what we hope that the
bottom basically falls off this graph
ideally meaning that there is no noise
or Distortion allowing this bottom to be
infinitely low nothing's going to be
that way but fortunately this device uh
this amplifier topping La 90 is great
that's superbly well I usually just
eyeball where these are all
intermodulation distortions by the way
so these are distortions that are
created as a result of these each one of
these things generating harmonic
Distortion and they get some together
this and if I already bothered and
convert that to decibel and convert that
to bits from decibel which is just
dividing by six I get 21 bits of
distortion free at 5 Watts so this is
again the Distortion it's just well
below your music and your threshold of
hearing just shows how great this is the
other thing is that it shows that the
Distortion level doesn't change with
frequency I'll show you other amplifiers
where this thing can climb up or the low
frequencies can climb up so you can see
a pattern in here and this kind of
pattern is great which is that the value
is low and is frequency independent
okay now all this stuff is good but
there's a secondary uh things you want
to care about the number one thing you
usually care about amplifier is having
more power than you ever possibly need
let me repeat you want to have more
power than you possibly need and you
always need more power than you think
most people have very wrong impression
of how many DBS they're actually playing
and and they keep thinking that you know
they're less than they got 70 DB or
whatever that's just never the case 70
DB at 20 Hertz is completely inaudible
so if you're hearing bass down down that
low you're way above 70 maybe so nothing
distorts more than an amplifier that has
cooked which means that it's reaches
maximum power can't go any hard and you
can see an example of that the moment
the sample fire eclipse look at how
Distortion shoots up and this becomes
instantly audible it's crackling
garbling muting
um so you want to avoid this you don't
want your Peaks to hit it and certainly
not your average uh all this thing so I
always plot this and along the way
um so this is a sweet basically we
change the input signal from very low
levels to the point where it causes a
slipping so naturally we see a you know
some kind of response in here this La 90
the reference in here is a benchmark hv2
again uh which is the stash for blue
line that for longest I'm no amplifier
could beat but now we have this uh 600
amplifier
outperforming it on on noise level uh
this part of the graph that's pointing
down
as we increase power it gets better and
better means we're just seeing noise the
impact of noise
um until the graph starts to point back
up that's when we know that distortion
is starting to take over so up to this
point almost to max power the sample for
is basically noise limited it's
Distortion it's just solo and what noise
it has Beats uh my best case reference
so it is way into state-of-the-art class
leading type of performance over here uh
the drawback for this amplifier though
is that it only produces about 70 Watts
so The Benchmark on the other hand
produce 163 Watts so 70 watts is not a
lot of power I'll show later on that you
can bridge this uh amplifier and get
more power out of it but here you're
getting incredible accuracy but this is
not a Powerhouse type of amplifier is
medium level of power if that
um now where I put this cursor in here
is sort of approximates these
measurements jump from point to point in
here there's it's not doesn't have
infinite resolution so sometimes this
point is not very accurate and at any
rate this point in this amplifier may be
way down here way up here for example
here we see that the Benchmark was a
little bit lower Distortion another
round may have a curve that's up here so
it becomes rather unfair to compare
where the clipping occurs for that I've
created a standardized test where I
measure how much power we get into the
same condition this is Forum by the way
Forum low uh and one kilohertz but we
measure how much power we get until we
hit one percent uh total harmonic
Distortion and where did one percent
come from I picked it as a probably a
reasonable value that's inaudible to
many people it won't be inaudible for
everybody but I sort of picked as a
reasonable value that maybe your Peaks
can hit it and be okay but by measuring
every amplifier at one percent now this
number is comparable to other amps so
you can take this number and if another
amp puts out 150 watts then great that
amplifier has got more power
um uh the amplifier specs are nightmare
in this area every one of them's got
made up power numbers so you want to
ignore anything that the manufacturers
tell you unless they show you this graph
or this what they're telling you is
completely bogus and some of them get
crazy bogus you can buy a 300 amp that
obviously advertises 6000 Watts so
go buy those things we must measure we
don't measure you know you don't know
what you have in an amplifier you
absolutely do not so we got to do this
now some people say well you know that
you're measuring an amplifier with A
continuous tone uh music has Dynamics in
it and you know bass note comes and go
boom and it goes away maybe last 20 30
milliseconds
um maybe the amplifier produces more
power if you let it do that indeed
amplifiers have a power supply with a
reservoir capacitor that for short
duration is able to produce more power
than it can continuously so I have
designed the second test that complies
with this standard called CEO 2006
490a it was designed to try to Corral
the uh call amplifier guys who go nuts
with these specs and it is a burst sine
wave so it goes up and comes back down
and uh you know it complies with the
specification go look that up but I pick
one percent again for consistency
consistency with this number so and we
can see that short term this amplifier
can produce 93 Watts uh versus 86 Watts
a more continuous thing uh Power uh not
a whole lot of Headroom you will see a
lot more hint from when I measure two
channels out of a let's say nine Channel
audio video receiver they'll have a
giant power supply designed to power
many amplifier channels but if you're
just measuring two channels you're able
to get a lot more Headroom out of them
so oftentimes you can get 20 30 Headroom
out of those things more headphones
better because that means you won't hit
that clipping Point as easy
so that was Forum
um you should know that about 80 to 90
percent of the passive speakers are
tests are at 4 ohm or 3.5 ohm or 4.2
ohms that all within this forum region
I'll show you eight ohm which used to be
the the thing that we always looked at
in the old days but just know that you
know if you don't know any better and I
publish the impedance for for uh
speakers that I test but if you don't
know just as humans for home and again
those companies lie a secret companies
lie about the impedance for the most
part so just assume forum and this is
basically a power you're going to get
but just in case you do know and you
care about 8 ohm I measure that too
um the uh when we go up to eight ohm our
power drops because the you know the uh
impedance the the way we compute power
is that voltage squared divided by the
uh impedance and if you double the
impedance you basically could have the
power so we can see the power drops to
only 41 Watts uh on this thing so uh not
a very powerful amplifier compared to
the two maps and things like that still
a lot of power but in general you know
you you uh you do lose something
um here I have a reference of another
great amplifier class the amplifier by a
company called purify I and you can see
it's performance over here is this Dash
blue line and there's this massive
Improvement in noise figure uh for uh
topping in here so performs very well
but again it can't compete on available
pal
okay now this graph is not very
revealing it's actually very good that's
not revealing I'll show you where where
normally uh what it normally looks like
um I've I said that this is at one
kilohertz this is what our power Suite
looks like at one kilohertz but uh you
know we care about what power at lower
frequencies or we care about power at
higher frequency so I actually run these
sweeps into four ohm but I do it at all
these uh frequencies
um from 20 Hertz all the way up to 20
kilohertz although I don't always show
that 20 Killers one usually stop at 15
kilos for reasons I won't get into uh
right now and ideal amplifier would have
all the lines on top of each other and
indeed that's exactly what we see in
here basically this amplifier does not
care what frequencies you tell to play
except when you get down to 20 Hertz you
lose power and this happens with every
amplifier that I test so all at higher
frequencies it actually has more power
than at 20 Hertz 20 Hertz the sine wave
move so slowly that it sucks all the
juice out of the output capacity the
power supply capacitors so it winds up
clipping sooner and so a lot of
Pentatonix people say ah no power
amplifier is good enough I don't need
more than 50 Watts well yeah 50 Watts
remember that's that one kilohertz what
does it give you at 20 Hertz or 30 years
or 40 Hertz and it may be half of that
on that so you got to be careful I think
when looking at that
this is a more recent test that I've
added uh thanks a useful thing to Ron
which is um what happens if you turn the
amplifier on and what happens when you
shut it off does it make any kind of
noise and I started to measure that so
what I do is that I start with the
amplifier off and I start recording it
so ignore this time thing is basically
it's a running
measurement of what am I seeing out of
an amplifier as just as if you hooked up
a voltmeter to it so when it's off it's
got this very low two micro volts so if
no one's coming out of it at this point
I've turned on the power button and
indeed it creates a glitch the glitch
though is not even one millivolts one
millivolts over here so this is probably
not audible uh uh on this thing now you
could have an ultra sensitive speaker
and it could make it audible but
anything less than a millivolt is likely
not audible so but after the glitch is
done it goes back to his idle level
noise and so I let it run and then I
power it off and the power of it
actually generates a larger pop and now
it gets up to three or four millivolts
and that may be audible in some speakers
um you know and not on others I've
measured others they're much worse than
this and then once it shuts off it goes
down to you know where it started so if
you care about that you know some people
are quite annoyed with the Pops that
they hear when they turn on and off so
apple farms are really bad in that
regard and worry about even damaging
their Twitters you know you want to pay
attention to this
on this thing
um the uh the other tests I run um but
not before she said I don't just turn
them on and measure them I let them warm
up and stabilize
um on this uh amplifier I've got an odd
response in that one channel will stable
as a rocket didn't care but the other
channel actually was little unhappy and
then became happy after about 40-50
seconds uh this tells you whether
leaving an amplifier on will do you any
good
um I'd say 50 of time I find that the
performance gets worse as the amplifier
warms up not better so a lot of people
think oh it's like my car engines needs
to warm up like no depends on the design
parameters sometimes when components get
hotter the noise level goes up and and
they don't always behave that way but
this is an exceptionally well engineered
amplifier and and become stable like I
said instantly in one channel the other
one took a little bit of time maybe
other samples won't do that so extremely
good but you know you want to be anal
about it if you don't wait a minute and
you'll get the best performance on this
um not all amplifiers allow bridging but
this one does went through the work of
measuring that also doubles my workload
so we're up to five Watts again and here
cyanide is basically not impacted the
Distortion profile changes uh on this
thing and the good news here is that we
now get a ton of power uh look at this
we now get quadrupled the amount of
power and and actually beat The
Benchmark hp2 both in power now and
noise and Distortion which is just
remarkable considering that this is a
little desktop amp and and doesn't weigh
a ton and the 279 watts should be plenty
now it does does double your cost
because now you're using two channels
for one speaker when you bridge them but
this scalability is just wonderful and
if I allow one percent look at this we
actually got 300 Auto Plus 320 watts of
power on this thing so that's just
wonderful
um I will cover this in a future video
but up until now you could critique and
say well all your measurements have been
with resistors and speakers on resistors
they have the correct capacitive or
inductive well I've got a new
um uh load speaker load that actually
lets me uh dial in whether I want to
have a capacitive or inductive and by
how much and here you can see that I've
run that at 8 ohm at 4 ohm the
protection circuit uh on the amplifier
would shut down and because of the
limitation in the software I couldn't
test it out for Forum it wasn't the
fault of the apple farm but uh it just
wasn't compatible with discount blood
testing but good news that ate home it
did not care at all I could make it
fully inductive and fully capacitive and
it just didn't care and uh
you know it ran fine the load also can
go all the way down to one ohm so I did
select two ohm and a two ohm the
amplifier quickly shut off uh so it
didn't uh you know it doesn't support
two ohms
um but the good news is that when I'm
running this test it's really really
pushing the amplifier hard uh it keeps
switching it to clipping Point multiple
times to try to ascertain the maximum
amount of power that you can produce and
with capacitive and and the inductive
loads so if the amplifier is going to
oscillate and things like that and kill
itself you're probably going to do that
in this test now it's not a full-blown
reliability test but you know it does
stress the amplifier and the amplifier
got pretty warm uh when I was subjecting
into this test
okay so this is what a state-of-the-art
amplifier looks like as far as
measurements and so forth
um it's uh you know it's a mid-level in
pricing is eight hundred dollars for two
channels and if you want to have user
and bridge mode you wind up at sixteen
hundred dollars
um but uh so now let's go lower in price
and see what we get when we go lower in
price
um for that uh we have fossil audios
bt20a uh Pro
um Amplifier company sent this to me for
testing
it's a little guy cost a hundred dollars
although they have a 20 discount for ASR
members right now so you can get it for
80 bucks and comes with a 32 volt uh
external power supply or you can get a
48 volt one which was my favorite that
costs you an extra forty dollars to get
um and you can see the size of the power
supply
bigger than the amplifier itself the app
itself is Tiny and uh it there are a lot
of these apps on Amazon AliExpress and
so forth but what distinguishes this
apps that they listen to us uh or me and
others complaining that whenever these
things have tone controls you set them
in the middle they don't generate flat
response you have no idea what the
frequency response of the amplifier is
and it's never flat because the the
parts that they use for these things are
not calibrated this company actually
work hard to make sure if you set these
things to the center detent it actually
produces the flat frequency response
which is quite nice and uh so I was
happy to see that
um so we go ahead and run our dashboard
again and uh again remember we have one
killer Stone in here and look at what
happened to the noise floor now instead
of being way down here buried at the
bottom of it that a lot higher noise in
here we have uh some unknown spikes in
here I don't know what the causes for
these things are
um then we have a dominant third
harmonic in here and not much else in
there the third harmonic is now at -90
whereas before the other amplifier we're
at minus 125 so quite a bit higher uh
but again remember it's only spending a
hundred dollars for this amplifier uh
the gain is as 29 DB I'll explain a lot
of amplifiers uh have higher gains and
THX has a standard for uh amplifier
games 29 DB so whenever I have a choice
in this case I had a volume control I
set it to 29 DB You could argue that
since the other amps are now lower gain
that maybe get a little bit better
perform if I set them lower and it would
be valid but I don't know how to solve
this problem with every amplifier has a
different uh gain setting okay so this
is with a 48 volt power supply in this
case I had to repeat every test with
then plug in 32 volt power supply and
luckily the cyanide did not change at
all now look at where this little guy
for 100 look at where it landed uh the
median is somewhere in here and you can
see this amplifier despite being only
100 bucks is way above average in this
green category which I call very good
category you know blue is is really save
the art stuff but I'd like to see an
amplifier landed this green area a lot
of times the cheap amplifier will say
well I like it only cost 100 bucks I you
know I'm down here but now I mean this
shows that you can't be up here this
amplifiers by the way use ICS from
companies like TI or Steve macros and
other these are major companies that
make amplifier ICS that go inside
smarter speakers and boomboxes and
things of that sort and and these
companies are put him in a standalone
Hi-Fi amplifiers in here so uh their job
is to extract the best performance they
can out of these this silicon and in
this case clearly they've done a decent
job in here
um now this graph is an eye chart you
can click on it and and rotate it
yourself if you want to look at all of
them in here and every amplifiers in
here or if you just care about what is
the neighboring uh you know amplifiers
in here I zoom in and look at this this
is a dead-on AVR I think that's a
fifteen hundred dollar AVR over here
and uh there's another then on here look
at this PS audio m700 there's a company
sell you you know expensive amplifiers
and tell you that you know they're great
and uh yet when it comes to noise and
Distortion this little 99 Box Hero
matches or or beats them you can see
other ones over here and and you know
what's down here
okay
um so uh we also then go look at the
noise performance uh we only get 84 DB I
like to see 96 DB here by the way so 16
bit same as a CD now this is 14 bits but
you know again we're talking about 99
amplifier so for the class it's pretty
good for a budget amplifier or you know
price of two or three fast food meals
you know you get there if you go to full
power it actually clears a 16-bit hurdle
so this is quite good uh for you know if
you use a typical speaker you shouldn't
be hearing much inside of it but we do
have a problem with these uh IC ample
bars they're all classy amplifiers and
in the class D's have this uh carrier
searching frequency that's you know
above audible band and uh uh it's part
of the operation of the amplifier but to
uh you know when releasing amplifier
with that noise coming out so they put a
filter in there and that filter then
becomes in parallel with your speaker
load and can change the frequency
response so at Forum we see a response
that yeah it's not ruler flat but it's
only 0.7 DB down at The Rim but if I
change it to 8 ohm look at the large
transformation in here I shouldn't say
large I've measured other amplifiers but
this thing Peaks way the heck up here
and comes down this is a very Amplified
scale it's only plus five or minus five
DB so this is zoomed in so worst case in
here we got 1.5 DB of peaking and that
happens around 60 70 kilohertz at 20
kilohertz it's only half a DB or 1 DB
higher so yes you're going to get low
dependency so some speakers you hook up
to this amplifier may sound a little bit
more bright or a little bit more muffled
depending on how good your hearing is
most of us are older we're down here so
the difference is much smaller uh but
you know ideally you want to get a flat
response and to get Flappers once you
have to pay more there's no 99 amplifier
that I know that that can produce a flat
response with as much power as this guy
does you can get a Class A B amplifier
that that's fine but you'll pay penalty
and available power as we'll get to in a
second okay
multi-tone and entirely different
pictures in the topping we're not in the
same class so we see that the noise
floors gone way up and there's spikes
here and there but where our hearing is
most sensitive again is around here and
if I compute the dynamic range we're
talking about 14 to 17 bits of
distortion free range this should say
Distortion free not dynamic range
um so you know it could be a lot worse
you could be you know down here where
you got severe Distortion you know over
here is you you know you're getting
competent performance but you're not
getting Stevia so that's what a sort of
medium or above medium level uh device
performs crosstalks is actually
excellent remember this is a thirty
dollar app that looks just like this one
and look at how bad it is this one is
very good Channel separation in here
uh this is what a killer surprise for me
was for this little amplifier was that
with four ohm and uh I believe this is
with you know 48 volt power supply it
produces 146 watt stereo this is all
these crafts are in Stereo so it's
essentially 300 watts of power is coming
out of this little hundred dollar little
box this big it's just insane and his
noise actually quite good uh Distortion
takes over when this graph goes up
remember so up to 20 watts is basically
noises your only issue but as you go up
it starts to creep up and then this
going backwards means the protection
circuit the limiter has kicked in and to
protect the amplifier and won't let it
go any hard in this so you don't want to
operate in this region but boy 146 watts
of power and if I allow one percent that
was already at one percent up here we
don't get much more but look at the
burst Power Burst his 180 watts per
Channel now we've got talking 360 Watts
total and stereo coming out of this
little box well yeah you got a 48 volt
brick power supply so even with the 80
now you have decent amount of power or
70 watts of power coming out of this
thing and and I did go around this thing
on one person for uh
uh eight ohm oh no sorry this is for the
32 volt power supply which is stock with
it so 32 volt power supply you know does
give you less power on this thing so you
do want to get the 48 volt one if you
want to be serious so In fairness it's
140 at amplifier minus 20 bucks if you
buy it with ASR discount code
okay
um we switched to Adam over here and uh
you know we lose power obviously but
you're still 100 watts of power and uh
uh with 32 volt power supply we take a
big hit because the hard impedance The
More Voltage you need in an amplifier so
the 32 volt one really takes a hit in
power but the 48 volt one still breaks
three digit numbers as far as power okay
now remember the topping when I change
the frequencies all the lines were on
top of each other not so here
um the higher frequencies generate
higher amount of noise and Distortion up
here but as I go down here it gets lower
and lower till I get to 20 Hertz and 20
Hertz this Orange Line gets a lot worse
than it goes back up here uh luckily it
produces almost the same amount of power
about 90 95 watts of this deck so for
this class is this is actually quite
excellent the fact that these are smooth
it's quite excellent
so very respectable for a little budget
amplifier okay
and this is the on off performance I
won't dig into it but you can see what
happens when you turn it on and notice
here when I turn it off now we're up to
10 or 15 millivolts and indeed I hooked
it up to my Infinities Tower speakers
and I could hear faint tick so just to
calibrate you used at about 10
millivolts is audible on you know so
typical speaker on this thing okay so
that was our second example where sort
of middle of the road but budget spear
amplifier uh but now let's go to luxury
uh products
uh and here we have a beautiful luxman
amplifier the uh uh SQ N150
um and uh uh tube amplifier beautiful uh
uh view meters small but nice
because they're thirty three hundred
dollars so a lot more expensive
long do this thing uh I won't bore you
with the details in here uh they even
are nice to show a block diagram and
rougher schematic in here and so if
you're a tube guy you can dig into that
so let's look at our uh dashboard again
boy is the picture
uh we're still at the same five watts
and we've got the 26 DB of gain
um but look at what happens first of all
we have all this power supply noise uh
you know there's no reason to have this
much power supply noise at just five
Watts uh all of this with good design
should be suppressed down to nothing
just because you have tubes doesn't mean
you can have all this power supply notes
yes there are some
um uh tube designs that generate this
but you want to avoid that though
there's I don't care who you are you
can't make a case to me the listening
power supply noise and harmonics uh it's
a good thing it makes the amplifier more
musical it's just not going to do that
and the notion that
harmonic Distortion out of tube
amplifiers is usually just second
harmonic and therefore that's more
pleasing and doesn't have higher order
ones well this one has high order one
still it's got one at three kilohertz
and then bunch more that go on to
Infinity over here so very bad showing
so we combine the noise and Distortion
together and I cyanide drops to
effectively uh 48 dbm look at where it
lands that's the second worst amplifier
I've ever ever measured uh as far as uh
noise bus Distortion so we had a 100
amplifier here and now we got a 4 000
alarm profile lining way down here
um the dynamic range actually
surprisingly wasn't as bad as I thought
it was going to be about 85 86 DB uh
I've measured worse so this is not bad
but obviously you know you want
state-of-the-art at these kinds of money
um frequency response is not flat it's
got some kinks in it but luckily within
audible band is is more or less flat so
from that point of view it's good what's
not so good is the crosstalk look at
what the crosstalk looks like usually
crosstalk work I guess worse at higher
frequencies because of
um straight capacitance causes uh higher
frequencies to couple between the
channels more than lower frequencies
this one actually has constant amount of
bleeding from one channel to the other
that tells me that there's a basically a
direct path between the left and right
channel it is just broken it just this
should not happen uh not in an absolute
level it's low enough probably not being
audible consumed but from engineering
point of view is just awful so whoever
takes this amplify and Raves about how
Sound Stage is better than you know
solid state amplifier and so forth is
quite wrong because you know this is
actually bleeding from one channel to
the other so if anything sounds safe
should be worse
um then we get into multi-tone and what
a disaster we have in here
um worst case which is down here we only
have seven bits of this Distortion free
best case is only 11 bit so if you're
playing music it's got all these notes
playing you have so little clean sound
coming out of this amplifier all this is
masking and destroying the low level
detail in your music all the music
detail in here is just stepped on
stomped down by harmonic Distortion and
intermodulation so again somebody waxes
poetic about this amplifier I mean so
Musical and they can hear all the
details they can hear as if then those
singers right in the room with them no
you're not here to doing any of that
because look at how much intermodulation
noise this thing is generating and the
more tones you have with music has
thousands and thousands or you know
close to infinite
um then the worse this gets so
definitely not the case of of goodness
in there now bad news continues look at
the graph now we have low uh noise
dominated up to maybe one-fifth of a
watt starting at one-fifth of the Watts
what we haven't even gone to one watt
Distortion starts to take over and
typical of these kind of tube amps and
low feedback amps
Distortion gradually Rises but it starts
so early but by the time we get to max
power we're way up here in Distortion
and we only got 12 watts of power out of
this thing 1 to 12 Watts
I mean that's like Candlelight level the
power I suppose I'm concerned I don't
know what kind of speaker you have to
drive they only need 12 watts and then
at 12 Watts you got all this Distortion
you're pumping in you know clean power
is less than half of what okay that's
what and even that's not clean look at
how high this is relative to our
referencing
um so uh on this thing so uh eight ohm
sorry this is four ohm that was eight
ohm and this is four ohm and you know
same bad picture in there so now we've
got only 10 watts about
um allowing for more Distortion doesn't
help you uh it actually penalizes you
because those graphs actually have more
than at more than one percent uh
harmonic Distortion so only got 11 do I
watch you got this giant big chassis it
looks beautiful but for what it's
supposed to do it can't do and look at
what it's doing now it linearly
increases Distortion with frequency it
goes up uh they're smooth which I guess
you could say is good but they're so
high these lines need to be way down
here not way up here and look at what it
does at 20 Hertz is definitely not happy
driving low frequencies at all and so
you know
you're raving about the base there I
don't know what to talk
um I won't get into the phone and say
it's uh we'll do another video on that
there's a headphone amplifier and and
I'm not going to talk about that either
um I do uh whenever I see something this
uh bad I do perform listening tests
um and in this case you know I just not
having enough power was just so apparent
to me that you know you just turn up the
volume and as I know in here you
actually literally literally it starts
to crackle uh on this thing but uh you
know if you lower the volume it just
sounds awful uh on this thing and I did
a a b comparisons making sure it's not
me and I put a topping pa5 and there's a
replacement and the boominess I was
hearing I was no longer hearing it which
tells me that the frequency response of
the amplifier had modified based on the
actual speaker mode that that I was
connecting to it or the harmonic
Distortion out of that 20 Hertz this
poor performance here of 20 Hertz well
was causing more room modes to be
activated so to me it just sounded
horrible you basically had very little
volume was kind of okay but anything
more than that it was just a disaster
yes if you have a more sensitive speaker
and you don't play as loud maybe it's
okay but I certainly heard no magic
there's no tube magic to me or anything
like that are you welcome to ignore my
subjective remarks but I'll put them in
there for people so while you're just
measuring and then listen well I do
listen when you know distortion's so
high that it's good to quantify you know
qualify them in this case
so no recommendation obviously on this
deck
so another long video 49 minutes I
apologize for that but hopefully with
these examples you got a good feel for
how powerful measurements are again you
know how nicely we can quantify how
noisy speaker is how transparent it is
what externality is how much power it
has and uh you know and this information
you cannot get out of Manufacturers
unfortunately even the ones that give
you a spec is sparse you don't even know
how the stuff was measured anybody ever
compliance by the way is saying oh your
measurements are wrong here's my data
ask him for graphs you know one number
means nothing what if I just told you
this amplifier produces 12 Watts that
tells you nothing you know until you
look at this graph and say whoa forget
about the world was Distortion started
at half a while this is super important
to see so you know you want to see this
kind of measurement so manufacturers
it's not as as our measurements are not
accurate here's my number I've got 0.01
Distortion it's like what does that mean
yeah the meaning you know what are the
conditions in here and you want to get
the conditions of of the test and that's
what determines then you know what the
value would mean and you really want to
see the full sweeps at many different uh
data points in here it's not just one
number a lot of people say oh you just
don't you go all about just sign in like
no that was start of the story but even
that wasn't the start the start was was
this picture you know first my eye goes
in here and says all right what are we
producing that we don't one all this
junk we were producing we don't want so
yes that turns into cyanide but then we
went on and on and on and on and on and
on and we keep looking at the amplifier
from a different Vector different test
conditions and and at the end a picture
pops out and a picture that pops up the
sample version it has no redeeming
quality as far as audio performance it's
gorgeous to look at and if looking at it
and you know it's important which it is
to me by the way
uh then you know you're golden this is a
gorgeous amplifier much prettier than
the the other two ounces I showed you
but you know the moment I hear it to me
it's like well you know I don't I will
never turn the signal
okay
all right so we'll continue on to cover
the other categories in future videos
thanks for being patient and listening
to my long presentation okay bye-bye